neither cake nor cookie a brownie is
something in between a moist dense and
chewy square
to mass-produce brownies this Factory
starts with canola oil they add xanthan
gum a natural preservative that
increases moisture retention during
baking
they blend these two ingredients in an
industrial mixer then they add sugar
cocoa and canola and palm oil shortening
they reactivate the mixer and it blends
the ingredients into a chocolate batter
the next ingredients are whole eggs and
corn syrup
the massive mixing arm descends back
into the bowl and whips these
ingredients into the batter
a worker wheels the bowl to a hopper
which releases a precise amount of flour
the flour thickens the mix it will give
the baked brownies structure they
transfer the smooth chocolaty mixture to
a machine called a depositor a sprayer
mist the pans with oil to keep the
brownies from sticking to them during
baking
then the pans arrive at the depositor
next the pans enter in eleven and a half
foot oven
the brownies rotate through 13 tiers to
bake them evenly after about 20 minutes
the brownies are cooked
they exit the oven and head into a
cooling chamber
like the oven it's multi-tiered the pans
move through it as fans cool the
brownies then a robot arm with
needle-like claws lifts them out of the
pans and transfers them to the next
conveyor at the end of the line a worker
places the brownies at a narrow conveyor
system that takes them to the wrapping
station a computer sensor detects their
approach and alerts the plastic wrapping
system ahead the plastic unwinds into
the wrapping machine as the brownies
enter it
metal wheels with grooves pull the
wrapper under the brownies and then
heated wheels melt the seam to close it
a hot shawl then seals and severs the
plastic film between the Browning's
creating individual packets it takes
about an hour to make and package
brownies at this Factory but only a
fraction of that time to enjoy them
you